[Music]
there were a lot of surprises this year
I played a lot of games that I didn't
know we're going to be as amazing as
they ended up being and one of those
wonderful surprises this year was soma
it's from the same developers as amnesia
Dark Descent so you'd imagine it to be
this super terrifying immersive horror
experience but soma is something else
something completely unexpected I don't
I don't want to give away too much but
it's incredibly immersive imagine
Bioshock but you get to go out into the
water and explore the underwater world
so you're kind of in this world that
used to be something great it's now
completely destroyed it's absolutely
beautiful and I love the water life I
love exploring the world but most
importantly and what really stuck with
me was concept of humanity and what it
means to be human the next one on my
list is not so much of a surprise
because I played this at different
places throughout the year and I've been
looking forward to it since the initial
reboot a few years ago it's Tomb Raider
and rise of the Tomb Raider and this
game is expectedly great I thought it
was gonna be wonderful I really enjoyed
every time I've been able to get my
hands on it and then when the game
actually came out it was what I wanted
you get to raid tombs you get these
great puzzles you get a wonderful
character experience like Lara is my
homegirl and I love the idea of solving
rich puzzles and figuring out these
ancient secrets and then shooting some
bad dudes in the face there's even
combat puzzles so there's this one
experience where you're under the ice
and there's all these dudes around you
and you have to be able to take them out
silently you can't actually come out of
the ice so you're just kind of dropping
them like slides one by one and I love
those tombs I love the puzzles and I
love the combat and I love
easy-easy game on my left so going back
to surprises something that I did not
expect to love as much as I did was a
little game called Ori and the blind
forest
twas a Metroidvania style game that had
so much heart and so much love built
into it I loved Metroid style games and
this is the perfect example of that it's
a hardcore platformer that's disguised
as this adorable cutesy game so you're
playing this lovable little forest
sprite and within the very first opening
moments of the game I compared a lot to
Pixar's up because it's so emotional and
you really fall in love with these
characters but then you find out that it
is actually quite difficult of a
platformer in itself it's just an
all-encompassing good game especially if
you like platformers especially if you
like hardcore platformer Ori and the
blind forest it's an easy win next up is
another story driven surprise and that
was until dawn and what a crazy amount
of twists and surprises within the game
but also the game itself I had no idea I
was going to enjoy it as much as I did
just super enjoyed both loving and
hating these characters and thus trying
to save them and feeling terrible when
they died or not caring about them and
basically letting them die and it was
just this awesome power this like crazy
wielding of power of letting people
basically go to their deaths making
decisions that I knew would end in their
doom I thought it was really well done
and it just blew me away there's not a
game that came out this year that
touched my heart quite like rocket
League did
and that's why it's my favorite game of
2015 it's truly just gameplay perfection
I don't even really enjoy sports games
but I love rocket League I love how easy
it was to pick up but how much I've
learned over the course of playing this
game throughout the last few months
they've just unlocked all these
different modes there's all these
awesome items that you can pick up from
you know different hats or different
tails or different paint jobs to keep
you coming back there's always a reason
to come back I love everything about
this game and what's wonderful about it
is you don't need that much
you don't need deep immersive plots or
complicated rules or stupid sexy
witcher's all you need is a giant ball
and rocket powered battle cars that's
all you need it is a tremendous
perfection of a video game and I am
honored and stoked to tell you guys that
rocket league is the best game that came
out in 2015
[Music]